- Years ago, Alec said to me,
"when I propose to you, it will be
the best proposal ever."
(electronic music)
"Back to the Future" became
a part of our relationship
together, probably when
you showed me like,
your onesie footy pajamas.
- So we enlisted the help
of our very dear friend,
and fantastic photographer,
Ricky Middlesworth.
All we had to do was stand there,
Ricky had to make it what it is.
- And I just, on a wild hair,
decided to post the picture to Reddit.
(electronic music)
- Halloween is her
favorite movie of all time.
I get some of her friends to scoop her up,
and tell her that they're gonna
go on a walking tour of the locations
and then as she's
rounding an iconic corner,
Michael Myers will pop out.
Okay so, here's me
waiting for Kat to come.
- You must have been so nervous.
- I was so nervous and I didn't realize
that the mask was gonna make
it really hard for me to hear.
They start chanting, which
they're doing right now.
"(mumbling) well yell a little
louder, yay Haddonfield"
And then I pop out.
- Yay Haddonfield.
(laughing)
That's real.
- And from here, my memory
of this, I blacked out
in this moment.
- Really?
- I don't remember
getting down on the knee,
I remember once I was down.
It was important to me to
- Okay honey, stop talking.
(crying)
Oh look at that face.
Yeah.
(soft acoustic guitar)
Are you serious?
Were you serious?
- Yeah.
(soft acoustic guitar)
You can't predict what its actually
gonna be like in that moment, you know?
But its really special,
it's really amazing.
I'm glad we have it on film.
- Yeah.
- And we're getting married.
- I love you.
- Thank you for that.
- You're my best friend.
Knock me a little kiss.
- Alright.
- Thank you.